all right well i'm sorry they have to go
from adorable adorable to this but
he's back baby he's back in the saddle
again
you know do you know what honestly do
you know who has it the best
out of this whole universe sherman
sherman yeah no i'm serious i agree
he doesn't have to put up with it
anymore everything my
this is him on facebook everything my
phobic but i have a rainbow flag on my
front step of my house
so you getting beaten by a skinhead
while i stand back and sat
very convoluted sentence and uh
and by about it is nothing horribly
wrong
brother-in-law does in this house i keep
wow this is he's really bad he's i keep
on record he is the most foolish [ __ ]
phony person who literally is just my
sister's willing black slave
in these [ __ ] up waters why do these
people right
always end up being
more racist than the actual racists i
know
of course you know like the racists that
i know
that get you know scrutinized by the
media are just like
he's a black guy just want to leave me
alone stay away from my daughter like
which is whatever whatever but it's the
leftist guys that are always just like
what are you a plantation slave you
[ __ ]
uncle tom i'll whip you like a [ __ ]
slave you end
and you're like wait a minute i thought
you were the
weren't you the altruistic ones i
thought you were the good guys
just like [ __ ] plantation slave and
you're like
dude i know guys in the old that
wouldn't say that
he then says this is why i need a
girlfriend to move in with me this is
fantasy the big buff girlfriend
because with a woman in my life my
parents have to keep
uh anti face maskers
out of my house like two of the men on
this recording or each time
they come over from so many other places
this is the ramblings of a madman with a
woman in my life my mom will not be as
tolerant about how often my phony
transphobic black brother-in-law comes
over
as she is pretty much a closet racist
just like
he is transphobic remember he was
blaming sherman this whole time
sherman's gone now so he has a new
villain he needs a new villain
i i want to just point out cause i know
i pointed out last time that
i love how in his triumphant fantasy of
having a girlfriend
come and live with him and stand up for
him it's still in his parents hat like
he's still gonna
come here and live with me here and
sponge off my parents with me
none of his like his imagination is
funny like
he doesn't imagine anything where he's
like self-sufficient and self-reliant
and living on his own and
has a woman in his life it's when my
when i get a girlfriend to come move in
in this hell hole with me
then i'll be set and then it's like he's
already just assuming
that he's allowed to move a girl in
right which is also obnoxious well
there's an empty room
but is that not another layer of his
obnoxiousness where it's like
none of this has been discussed with
anybody it's just when i get a
girlfriend and move her in here and it's
like
no no no earl the goal should be
when you move out and then you get a
girlfriend and then you guys have a
plate then it's you guys
i would love to see him get a girlfriend
move out and get his own place
just because the posts would then become
she's
a sh oh but she beats me she's a
psychopath you're right i don't know
what she's doing to me
uh some people are new and they don't
know if you're looking for the entire
because i we can't explain it in one
sitting if you're looking for the entire
hypernova saga
it's on our clip channel uh youtube.com
rotc media they're all there's a
playlist of the dayton hypernova saga if
you want to see it
it's a lot of lore together it's it's a
whole bunch uh wizard got a good point
his girlfriend could live in the tin
foil room
can i keep you i'm gonna get a
girlfriend that will stand up for me and
she can
live in the attic we're surrounded by
tinfoil like a pot plant
um so this is a long one and with a lot
of grammatical errors my parents
actively
ignored payments owed to me the entire
month of january
and i didn't bother about it with their
son's death you mean your brother
i kept working for them every week
anyway tonight i told my dad
on camera in front of his religious good
deeds
a friend which he is a hypocrite about
and everywhere
about hypocrite about everywhere when
his friends is not here
that is not he needs to pay me for last
week's work in this week's work
and to not ignore payments anymore i
went easy on you last month because of
things
this so wait a minute but this went easy
on them this post
is all right like we've read a lot of
these earl
posts um he's not that coherent to begin
with he's obviously not that
well spoken but these are bad even for
him right
yes he's like i feel like he's probably
drinking a lot or doing something
because
those are the that's the they got these
pretzels here
[Music]
250 who are you crazy get out of here
when he writes march the love letter
it's that kind of rambling where you're
like
you need to not be writing or in public
right now or posting
the only way my dad was not snarky at me
in front of his
good deeds christian friends was by
mentioning to him i need the money
i'm working for especially if i work
with the lady mentioned who was
affiliated with
andy warhol's people he's working with
someone knows andy warhol's people he's
such a
bad stereotype right remember that time
he was talking of texting me for like
three months thinking i was a doctor
phil producer
because that's a thing that actually
happened and then he kept posting about
how he's talking to
the doctor oh my god but
it's just he really is every like
unlikable trope oh yeah you know that
hates the christianity
everything's a [ __ ] thing he's a
substance abuser he's it's just
everything is packed into this one guy
he stops being an [ __ ] to me when i
mention that i might eventually have to
mention her first name but avoid
mentioning her husband at all
or the last name this is literally how i
talk
my god awful hypocritical wealthy
parents into paying me
what they owe me when they afford
vacations multiple times a year yes but
you know what
dude they they afford vacations with
their money
earl with their money you live in their
house for free
you have absolutely no
legal stake in living there like they
could kick you out at any time
if they wanted to um they pay you
to do nothing and live in their house
they've put up with
these people have put up with a lot they
are [ __ ] saints at this point
let them they're allowed to go on vic
it's their money you're living in their
house
i don't could like i can't grasp like
you're living in somebody's house
and then they go all right uh i'm going
on vacation
i'm taking a week off do me a favor just
make sure the pets are taken care of
try not to trash the place and uh we'll
be back in two weeks and go
yeah yeah must be nice must be nice to
be rich and go on vacations and it's
like
you're living here for free what are you
talking about
this is a vacation earl your life has
been a vacation
so uh this is the video that he posted
in relation to those posts
uh carrying laundry upstairs and telling
my dad
well i need you to look at this look
it's one it's one long word
yeah carrying a laundry upstairs and
telling my dad they
have to pay me each week went easy on
them last month
all of earl's um all of dayton
hypernova's video titles
read like the titles of fallout boy
songs
yeah you know cute cute without the e
no that's taking back sunday um um
like fallout boy was was always like uh
um tell that mick he just made my list
of things to do today it was always
entire sentences he's like uh was the
other bandit ripped off fall out boy
a panic at the disco it's the same thing
they had entire sentences as song titles
and you're like this is annoying it's
like the title of a fraser episode the
one where frasier goes on vacation
all right let's check this one out i
fast forwarded after the pretzel bag
thing
or sun chips back can we stop saying
that because it's actually making me
hate sun chips i was good and i love sun
chips
i was gonna get sun chips the other day
and then i thought of that and i was
like i don't want him anymore
crunch
this is just a sun chip super bowl ad
crunchy crunch crunch
i promise you there's talking in here
somewhere here we go
i think you
so his dad is correctly pointing out
that i might not have paid you this
month but you used my credit card
remember he was using his credit card
to buy seven hundred dollars worth of
tin foil and he thinks that's just the
separate magic money
yes that doesn't need to be paid back or
anything it's like
no no that was yeah i just used your
credit card to order pizza
that has nothing to do with what i'm
entitled to you're like what
i'd have [ __ ] killed this guy by now
uh 325 i guess technically 25 dollars
[Music]
you know he's full of [ __ ] and you know
deep down he kind of knows he's full of
[ __ ]
because the way he's handling this with
like the
well you know it's like i was hoping
that i could get a couple you know
because you're supposed to pay me
or whatever like that sheepishness that
doesn't come out when you're really owed
money by somebody you've
worked hard for if you worked your ass
off for somebody they didn't pay you
you'd go hey
[ __ ] i want my [ __ ] money i'm
not [ __ ] playing around anymore
i did all my [ __ ] work we made a deal
that's how you say it when you're
somebody who hasn't been
stealing their credit cards and using
them and [ __ ] you know what i mean like
you go hey i want my goddamn
money
[Music]
the only way to bring it up is by
talking about this lady that i met
visiting in los angeles
[Music]
who worked with andy warhol before he
passed away in the 80s years
that's the only way to have a straight
conversation and they're so narcissistic
but that's the only conversation
this lady who i actually got in contact
with has been talking to me about my 3d
phone projects my 3d camera and stuff
that i'm trying to work on
the lady is either non-existent or
humorous pranking you or
lying to you because we've seen your 3d
camera project
it's aluminum foil earl
to be fair i mean andy warhol painted a
bunch of [ __ ] soup cans and sucked a
bunch of [ __ ]
so it's not like he was like you want to
talk about
overrated to begin with [ __ ] andy
warhol jesus
[ __ ] hack their relationship
with me as uh employer employee
situation
uh they do my own taxes they do my taxes
every young people active
of my income which is below minimum wage
200 a year which is ridiculous to make
that level of wage
uh you know this is 2021 i've been
making that lower voice since 2009
this this is one of these you don't work
you do laundry once a week
this is one of the classic hypernova
moves by the way is just complete
filibustering
which probably has worked for him in the
past like i can imagine many situations
where he just did this and babbled until
somebody's like all right here
here shut up go away just leave me alone
in fact i think it was even lower at
first i had enough arguing to make it
that
high of a thing 5200 a year
like that's ridiculous so anyway i've
lived on a meal of the day
for several years now for those months
the past several years
you live on a meal a day because you
choose to
i've heard your parents offer you a
bunch of food and you're like i don't
like those kind of wings
yeah i don't like though that's not the
pizza from the pizza place i like yeah
you're you're [ __ ]
stubborn selfish little which is why you
don't eat every time
you've shown a video of you and your
families there they're
all eating have you ever seen
a video when he's taping his family and
they're not eating
they're always over and having usually
when they're all there they're having a
meal or
remember they're outside barbecuing the
one time and the black brother-in-law
was like hey what up man
you want a hot dog and he was like wow
like
and it's like yeah they're all eating
like you're the prima donna you're the
one like rice said
i don't like that kind of pizza whereas
like even if it's shitty pizza if i walk
in any room and like royce is like you
want some pizza i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i'll get pizza even when it's
shitty pizza you're like you'll grab a
slime
pizza's pizza um his stupid health
burritos all this other [ __ ] it's like
oh i hate him i hate him i hate him i
hate him
just to save all my money
i think that's that's the end of this of
this particular video
you know even if these boomers [ __ ] up
with him which clearly they did because
they got two sons that are
you know that weren't exactly uh home
runs but
even even if you place
some of the blame on this on the parents
which you should it's a mixed bag
do you not still feel kind of bad for
them i still feel bad for
just having to like live in this this
prison
well there's a reason i feel bad for
them because they got a decent house
they got
you know what i mean outside of him
they got the you know the brother-in-law
with the kids and they come over and
it's like you know
i'm sure like any other family i'm sure
none of them are perfect no of course
but you know they interact and they get
the dinners and they're trying to be
[ __ ] they're all just trying to live
their lives
and this black [ __ ] hole is always
around
it's this is him explaining on camera my
transphobic sister and brother-in-law
exploiting a violent skinhead passing on
of course yes of course they are i mean
i granted it is the middle of winter
right now so i'm
just bundled up in sweaters
and you know you know staying warm
but i can't really wear dresses in this
house without crazy harassments
especially from what was a total bigot
wait she's picking it against
sweating sweater wearers no he can't
wear dresses in the house
extreme right-wing values from kentucky
awful bigots but then leave
uh once this andy warhol deal comes
through for his big potato room he will
leave mike
[ __ ] focus
see it's like it's like imagine
it's it's like it's like you're the
baked potato and that's why you're
looking
out at the foil oh i see you
and then here's my here's my the uh
steering wheel from a boat with a swirl
thing on it
it's so bad everything is so petty it's
i stuck a swirl thing on it
in the same pattern as the old cookies
that used to come with dunkaroos oh yeah
those remember those
yeah like
i call this one led
um
awful all of these people
purely exploit a situation for
themselves
is he saying other people are exploiting
a situation yeah they're all
they're all the ones doing the things
he's actually doing
but i don't i've never felt even even
growing up in in a
admittedly in retrospect probably
abusive household
i never felt this terrified and
trapped where i had to hide in rooms and
mumble to myself like
but if i felt that way anywhere
i would leave right like of course you
would just go
yeah i'm out of here even if you didn't
have the money or whatever you know what
i'm i'll figure it out
i'll figure it out all right i gotta go
i can't be here anymore
you people are literally beating me
every day
like you just have to go this like he's
bitching and bitching and bitching and
it's like you're an adult
man just leave this isn't a six this
isn't a video of a six-year-old going
i'm scared
and my mommy and daddy beat me and i
don't know where to go that would be
heart-wrenching you'd go like
poor [ __ ] kid you're an adult man
just leave seven and a half years of
beatings
violent beatings and harassments i've
suffered from erythrodermic psoriasis
so the genetic condition on my that
completely i'll just show my hands i
guess
it's hard to hold a camera ah ugh
oh my god he's got he's got hands like i
would imagine
ian mckellen's hands look like yeah what
the [ __ ]
but i mean don't mind the awful
you know what i just realized too do you
know how you could break
you know you could break dayton
hypernova just ask him the one thing
nobody ever asks him
you i guarantee you you could make this
guy almost have a stroke if you just sat
down and went all right you know what
fine let's
let's agree on everything everything
you're saying is true
what do you want
what do you want attention
but he'll never say i'll never admit it
so you go what is it what like
right now a path to to being whole
what is it what is it what do you want
them to do what is it you
want because you just [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what would what is the one thing you
want and i guarantee if he sat there and
thought about it long enough he might
actually just kill him
remember when his dad he doesn't know
what he wants he just wants to complain
his dad remember going on what you're
saying remember that time his dad
offered him three thousand dollars if he
would leave
he said i'll give you three thousand
dollars cash
no no where so anyway i mean
this is all psoriasis all over my legs
this bleeds
all over my body that bleeds all over my
body
uh from it because it's a rhythmic
psoriasis it's extreme
i know and you're right against you're
on had it it basically
uh it bleeds from stress
from any stress factors i mean i'm
scratching right there just because i'm
slightly nervous just because they're
right over and
they they're all known to bully me
they're all much lower known by whom
i'm very skinny i live on one meal a day
in this house
all all things you have control over
and i can't wear dresses in my house
without crazy things happening to me
from the family
and my imagine that's your biggest
complaint
you can't work directly you're choosing
not to eat enough and you're not allowed
to wear your dresses
did you were you even like you probably
were vetoed more often than not as a kid
when you wanted to express yourself
right
of course normal families no you're not
wearing that
no you're not getting your eyebrow
pierced to 12. get out of here you know
what i mean everybody
looks like the kid from [ __ ] big
daddy when adam sound let him dress
himself yes
and it's like that's that's a good like
you know i wouldn't have been able to
wear
dresses in the house either because it's
not your hot like
the whole point is like give it up you
know give some credit to some of these
at least they went okay you know what
i'm leaving this bigoted household
and i'm never coming back and they went
off and you know fixed up a house in
some black neighborhood
and pushed all the black people out and
they made their own way in the world
enablers of the violence they completely
exploit any of the situation
in their favor that's why i keep it all
on record
this is crazy i mean where do you go
when you have a rhythmic psoriasis all
over your body it's affected by the cold
climate outside
move somewhere warm that as well as well
as the stress factors
and these people move to a nice warm dry
climate in the desert yeah do you like
the movie tombstone
yeah get shot through your [ __ ] liver
while you're playing pool
and that's not the thing i bet but okay
yeah i want you to end up like
tombstone too like morgan earp and
tombstone
morgan earl morgan earl yes
morgan yes can somebody make that for us
please morgan earl
i love it god
dawg
pigs vegas pigs
[ __ ] everyone in the family is a
joke then leave but like maybe you're
the jerk right
because it's like i i think it's almost
universally accepted at this point
earl that you're the jerk that
that the jerk store called and they're
all out of you
sir it's not the other people
happy-go-lucky about it too ugh
i mean that's awful that brothers i've
been bring three
small kids around that's awful
but what does he want you know what i
mean
and i know it's like a rhetorical thing
i know there's there's no
legitimate answer to that but what do
you want
well mike i'll tell you what i want
[Music]
oh no oh no
[Music]
my name is
[Music]
get earlier fair it was cool
i never thought that i would see him
again
that's in the chat for sure
[Music]
but i
[Laughter]
he was clean for about an hour
[Music]
um
[Music]
this is
the fact that you did a puddle of mud
cover just makes you the man
now the footage is great too
for me to vent
to myself because there are no people
who
reach out to me during the meetings
[Laughter]
very good job i'm going to post post the
link
local enterprise broadcasting it's just
so good
it's so very good
there you go i hate him so much i hate
him so much um